hi I'm Rosario Dawson I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I am here to talk about my
first times starting what this is my
first time doing this game first time
you ever saw rent and for the first time
when I was around 24 yeah so just a few
years after it came out powerful it was
the first time I ever saw something that
highlighted my life story and made it
seem awesome because I grew up in a
squat in the Lower East Side and I
didn't know that folks that I grew up
with could be protagonists my first job
my first job actually I got paid $20 to
work on Sesame Street one of the people
who grew up in the squat that I grew up
in and one of the people who lived there
she was dating a cameraman on Sesame
Street and was working with children's
liberation we were doing a community
garden video which still exists today
and that's still the my favorite way to
get recognized when I've had little kids
come on like every night egg to me
straight I'm like yes I was first roll
you really wanted but didn't get dang
ready to go dark you know what the first
level that I really remember I got
actually I got the roll it was called
lift and I got offered the role and it
was between that or The Adventures of
Pluto Nash you know lift would have been
here in New York for no money a little
indie film or I could go to Canada and
shoot this movie with Eddie Murphy and
see what could happen and I remember my
mom and everybody arguing with me like
you need to get off this couch and so
Kerry Washington ended up doing the job
but I always remembered looking back on
that moment like did I mess up I've got
the wrong choice but I think it worked
out okay for the both of us all right
first thing you kept from a set I don't
remember keeping anything from kids
actually got things stolen from me when
I was 10 kids I'm going to go to
rehearsal
on my bicycle and it getting stolen by
the time I came out from her stall it
was great but the first thing I kept
from a set was on he got game it's a
spike Lee movie set in Coney Island
Brooklyn which is actually where I was
born my character went to Lincoln High
School which is the high school that my
mom and all of my uncle's went to and
she actually had to drop out of school
from there because she found out later
that she gets gestational diabetes when
she's pregnant so she can't produce
enough insulin for both her and the baby
so she kept passing out and then
eighteen years later I was shooting a
spike Lee movie they're doing a scene
right outside of Lincoln High School
with Denzel Washington and so I kept I
have these lincoln high school sweat
tracksuit outfit thing or whatever and I
kept that because I just thought that
was really cool that at one point
eighteen years earlier I was in the womb
there and now I was working on a spike
Lee joint my first audition no that's
easy I was for this movie called kids I
was hanging out on my stoop because my
dad told me to they were shooting a vibe
commercial on the block and my dad told
me to go downstairs and get discovered
because he overheard someone saying that
they wanted dancers and I went
downstairs and I did end up dancing in
the commercial but I scored my first
audition because Larry Clark and Harmony
Korine and a bunch of the crew were
walking by scouting for locations and
saw me and asked me if I'd auditioned
for kids and that changed my life
forever first kiss it didn't say with my
current boyfriend
and it's so funny actually I remember
having this conversation with Chloe and
kids because it happened that summer
when I turned 15 in Tompkins Square Park
and the skate the skate park now area I
think we're playing like truth or dare
or spin about something like that and I
ended up making out and thinking it was
not so great so in a scene I remember
her laughing going rosario because i was
telling her the story was like oh my god
i just had my first kiss kiss grant park
and her just being like because I was
really young even though I better really
promise to his character is very much
not like that more like first time I
knew I was famous for me the real
telltale of like Fame is walking down in
like around Central Park and seeing
those artists who were doing like
portraits for for money
and they always have like certain staple
people that they already have to show
what kind of you know what their heart
looks like and I still have never seen
anyone have my picture there to be like
see look how well I drew Rosario don't
you want to pay me some money too do you
report it
so until that day happens I still just I
just don't think it's happened still
working on it guys still working on it
first thing I do on my phone when I wake
up are usually I'm checking to see if my
boyfriend has sent me a song or a poem
or something that's going on in his day
because we have a lot of our
relationships long-distance and that's
our our messages in a bottle that we
send to each other first time I saw
myself in a magazine you know and I've
actually been trying to find this image
it's a picture I think it's in details
magazine and they were doing a profile
on squatters and it's a picture
black-and-white picture of my dad and I
in our living room I think we were past
the point of having a cast-iron stove in
the living room which was totally
illegal but the only way we stayed warm
but it was just like a picture of the
two of us like him sitting down on the
ground and I'm kind of like we're folded
on each other and just looking kind of
soberly at the camera and I remember
being so blown away because that photo
ended up coming up later in my life this
artist spotted me on the street and
asked if he could do my portrait and
when I went to his place there was this
photo this this this drawing of this
girl I really was like that really looks
like me and he was like no no that's off
of a girl I got out of a magazine and
then he proceeded to pull the magazine
out with the picture of me and my dad
and somehow this guy had drawn a
portrait of me when I was a young girl
and then all the years later spotted me
on the street and asked to draw my
portrait again which is kind of amazing
so I'm still looking for that magazine
first scene I remember filming with Yael
on Jane the Virgin my first scene with
Yael actually was in her office and
loving my like power suits and being
very bemused with her frantic and
incredible energy you know when I got
that job
it was Gina Rodriguez it reached out to
me over the holidays because they'd cast
that character already and actually shot
several scenes with her and an emergency
they needed to replace that actress the
scenes immediately very quickly because
they have to keep shooting and also you
know recut every film that stuff
and I have no idea where the character
was gonna end up going I had no idea we
were gonna end up having a tryst and I
love affair or whatever so it was just
it was kind of great because I don't
think my character obviously knew that
either it was just really awesome nails
incredible she just had a baby and I
loved her very much and I'm so grateful
for working on that first memory from
the josie and the pussycats set the
first one that comes to mind is we were
shooting this scene we were doing a
concert so we all had ears and tails on
and sparkly little outfits mm
outfits I was actually I wasn't smoking
cigarettes at the time I was still very
anti cigarette and but Rachel and Tara
were smoking so I went out with them
while they were smoking and we're just
talking with them and I remember both of
their eyes getting really big and being
like we need to go back inside right now
and I took me a second to realize what
was happening but there were all of
these girls because there was all these
extras and different people who are
around that day who were like touching
my hair and twirling my tail and like
just being very intimate with my costume
and myself and I hadn't noticed it was
that first moment where I felt like I'd
lost my New York card because I'd now
gotten so accustomed to being on set and
someone fidgeting with my mic and you
know adjusting my wardrobe and you know
just you know fixing touching up my hair
but I just ignored the feelings and I
was like never again
okay so first CD I bought and the reason
why I want to bring this up is pretty
cool is cuz back in the day you know you
went to a CD store to find music you can
just stream it and I wanted to have the
soundtrack to Reservoir Dogs and the CD
shop and Union Square didn't have it
doesn't even exist anymore that store so
I had to order it and I remember them
finally calling me and saying my CD came
in and it was just so great and I love
everything about it including all the
interludes that are on it and because of
that and all the years later ended up
working on death Proof with Quinton I
ended up winning five bucks in trivia
because I remembered how many dicks he
said in his opening monologue
and he didn't but that's because I
listened to that see
so much so so that was really really fun
thanks so much
I'm Rosario Dawson this is BuzzFeed and
please check out briar patch
enjoy
[Music]